- [Instructor] So we're
told here the four corners
of a rectangle are located
at the points (1,1), (1,6),
(9,6) and (9,1).
Plot the four corners of the rectangle
on the coordinate plane below.
And they gave us these four points
and we can move them around
with our mouse or our finger,
depending on what type of
a computer we are using.
And so let's just go
point by point and plot
the green points at those points.
So the first one is (1,1) and remember,
the first coordinate is our x-coordinate.
The second coordinate is our y-coordinate.
So the first coordinate
tells us how far do we move
to the right of the origin.
So it's one, and then
the second coordinate,
the y-coordinate, tells
us how far to move up
from the origin, so that's also a one.
So (1,1).
The next point is (1,6).
X-coordinate is one.
So we move one to the right of the origin
and then the y-coordinate is six.
So we move six up and notice
it's at the intersection
of the line ...
Or it's at the intersection
of when y equals six
and x equals one.
This is (1,6).
Alright, now we have (9,6).
So let's see, if we take our ...
If we have x equals nine right over there
and y is equal to six so we go up six.
So notice y is now equal to six.
And we have one last point to plot: (9,1).
So when x is nine, y is one.
We go nine to the right or
we're right above x equals nine
and then we go up one.
This is (9,1) and there you have it.
We have the four corners of our rectangle.
Then they say what is the
height of the rectangle?
Well if you imagine a
rectangle right over here,
the height would be the
distance between that point
and this point or the
and that point and so what is the distance
between these points?
Let's see, they're on ...
They both have the same x-coordinate
and this one is at y equals six.
This is at y equals one.
So this is five higher than this one.
So the height is five.
And we can also count it.
We could see one, two, three, four, five.